hi I'm Eric Minich with IBM cloud and I
want to talk about application
modernization and three huge
transformations that have been going on
together so we've got three things going
on they're interrelated and this is what
we're seeing this change in how we're
doing architecture infrastructure and
our ways of working how we deliver and
if we go back in time a little bit
you know we saw applications that were
very monolithic they were running on
physical servers and we used waterfall
style development where we'd have long
plans and we'd say okay this is gonna be
our planning phase or development phase
or testing phase and we could plan out a
year as a project and that's really what
we've gone away from so if we look at
how most organizations are working today
architectural II they've got some sort
of distributed architecture it's usually
related to like a service-oriented
architecture the the big buzzwords a few
years ago but some sort of distributed
architecture we have a bunch of web
services they're talking to each other
we got some databases on the backend and
then some front ends that kind of go
through all that on an infrastructure
level they're running on some sort of a
virtual machine alright so we said we
probably do better than having to order
a new server every time we have a new
service let's virtualize this stuff and
we need a little more density along the
way and from a way of working
you know agile development pretty normal
and then trying to figure out a little
bit of what happens downstream so this
kind of takes us up to where a lot of
teams are today but not really where
they're going and so if we look at kind
of that next phase we're taking another
pass at this service-oriented
architecture and really shrinking the
sizes of the
services taking advantage of the more
dynamic infrastructure we have and we're
calling these now micro services right
micro services so we've got a micro
service architecture so very small very
focused services moving away from a lot
of the heavyweight XML based
communication we saw and so uh towards
more rest based communication things
like that but same idea let's keep
breaking into smaller and smaller pieces
we have more independence of what we
ship more rigor and saying this service
needs to be independent from another
service so I can change these things by
themselves on the infrastructure side
cloud it's pretty popular and this could
be public cloud this could also be
private cloud I'm painting with a very
broad brush when I say cloud here and
then from a delivery in a way of working
we could say that DevOps is really key
and I would include in this approaches
like site reliability engineering sre
more the ways of working we have today
now that that's fine and interesting but
what do these things have to do with
each other and I'd argue that what we're
really seeing is modernization in how
the applications are delivered and how
they're built and what they are and
while you could walk into any large
enterprise today and you'll find someone
who says we are going through a cloud
trance transformation you'll often find
somebody says yes I'm in charge of
leading the DevOps transformation and
you'll walk into enterprise architecture
I'll say yes we are pushing micro
service architectures individuals think
that they're going through three
separate transformations but they're
really tied right
if I'm doing microservices right and I
have new microservices all the time
and in order to get a new micro service
up and running I'm overhearing I have to
order a new physical server and then
rack and stack it a couple months later
I'm not gonna get any time to market
benefits the resilience benefits that
I'm gonna normally look for from micro
services are going to be modest at best
right micro services want cloud
infrastructure you want to be able to
say I've got a new micro service let me
put it in a container and just run that
container right now and scale that
dynamically similarly cloud really likes
running microservices alright the
benefits of being able to dynamically
scale are really cool when you have a
lot of small things that you might need
few up or a lot of it's not as
interesting when I've got a monolith
that isn't even distributed how do i
scale that I get a bigger cloud server
and then all of this is kind of baking
in this idea of speed and resiliency and
DevOps
brings that together right the
developers who have always wanted speed
the operations people always wanted that
resiliency they're going to be
programming that cloud right the
programmable infrastructure the cloud
provides needs operations people who
understand resiliency but bring some of
that development skill it and to really
take advantage of these new
infrastructures the the new
architectures you need these new ways
working and you also are going to say if
this is going to give me time to market
benefits I can't be back here and say
yeah no we've got a one-year project
plan that we're just going to execute I
need to be able to be more agile and
adapt in my planning and my
responsiveness to the business I need to
better wire up my applications so they
can be more easily monitored and
and more resilient we have to have the
application in a way that it knows when
one of these services is failing and we
can spin up another so this is really
for me fascinating that you walk into
these organizations everywhere and
they're undergoing these three different
transformations but they're always doing
them together and when they don't
doesn't quite work so you've got these
three transformations going on at once
and you'll hear us talk a lot about
application modernization right so you
get written across the top here and when
I think of application modernization I
think it's just this it's this
transformation right here going from
these kind of monoliths or
service-oriented architectures to micro
services adopting cloud modernizing our
ways working towards DevOps and sre
that's at Mott all right and it's a
really exciting time and it's really
great when you're able to go after it in
a holistic fashion thank you if you have
questions please drop us a line and if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future be sure to like and subscribe